well good morning everybody I don't know
for streaming or not uh we're gonna find
out when Gen 4 gets here but I'd like to
welcome everybody to the higher
education study committee uh today we
have an agenda before us uh which
um involves input or uh insights we're
going to try to obtain from the both the
from the State University and from Keene
State College and I'd like to welcome
Brian Walker and Tanya Sturtz here
um Jen are we streaming
okay thank you very much
uh maybe but we ought to do is first
thing we do today is just go around the
table and everybody introduce themselves
so that we know who we are and Brian why
don't we start with you on the left-hand
side I always go left to right brought
up in Canada so it's the left hand you
know
my name's Brian Walker State University
I'm in that role I serve at the
licensure officer
to see our teacher education programs
basically to make sure that we need to
States since 2012 with initially
actually started with the state teacher
it's a microphone to it it's a red hit
the red button so you have to start all
over now
you say that means off okay
um but it's great to be here so thank
you
hi I'm Tanya sturt I am the director of
ed prep at King State College and also
chair of the education department and uh
so I oversee everything that has to do
with education from licensure compliance
accreditation and all those pieces so
and it's funny you I was like oh my god
I've been here since in New Hampshire
I'm not from New England I've been up
here since 2009 which Jay Khan was at
King State when I first started so it
time stamps how long I've been here
thank you for inviting us you're welcome
I I blew dollar theater States for
district 20. that's the city of
Manchester
I'm Ruth Ward
chair of the Senate education committee
I'm Rick glad I chair House Education
I've been here since 2008 not as long as
Senator Alexandria but
um uh been on the education all those
years my previous life was that of a I
started out after I graduated from
UMaine and then got my Master's there
but uh as an elementary teacher
then went on to become a Elementary
School principal and then a principal
slash School administrator up in Alaska
for 25 years
distinguished National principle so
education is what I like to talk about
and curriculum especially so I think
that's what our dock it's about today uh
so go ahead represent myelin uh Mel
Myler I'm ranking them on the house
education committee have been in the
house now this is my sixth term and I'm
the retired executive director of Nea
Dave luno I'm a State Rep from Hopkinton
bow in Concord serve on the education
committee and spent uh served 12 years
on the Hopkinton school board
will forgive him he's an engineer a
Shannon hi I'm Shannon Reed uh yeah I'm
director of government Affairs for the
community college system of New
Hampshire
Mark Rubinstein community college system
of New Hampshire
Jay Khan a former state senator member
of this committee for a couple of few
years and 28 years at Keene State
College and invited by the chair to come
because I've been working as a board
member for New Hampshire Civics and have
an interest in the topics that the
Germans and that's one of our topics for
today so yeah we'll have a discussion
and thank you all for coming and Dr
Rubenstein you're you're too Ma you know
he's been president Granite State
College now Chancellor of the community
college system so I'm very pleased to
have you here Mark but but not an MIT
trained engineer that well
well every committee
just keep things going he's our
spreadsheet analyst over here so we he
helps us out a lot when it comes to
education Finance so today we have an
agenda here and uh the first thing that
I would like to do is that we've had of
course this is education committee and
we deal with a lot of bills coming in
that are curriculum oriented we deal
with the academic standards and the
minimum standards for public school
approval
and in our looking at academic standards
we oftentimes Wonder uh we the State
Board sets those academic standards and
the schools then integrate those
standards into the curriculum which they
adopt and they approve locally
we oftentimes are wondering though when
we we're looking at some of the outcomes
that come out of the the classes and we
look at and there's a lot of ways of
having accountability we have the
Statewide assessment here but there's
some numerous ways as we all know of
being Educators how we can you know
ascertain whether a student has acquired
that skills and knowledge and Concepts
which we want but we are seeing things
starting to slide a little bit
especially in mathematics not just
because of covid but they're sliding
prior to that from last 10 years or so
we've seen the achievement scores not
being where they are whether the
achievement tests are measuring what
we're teaching I don't know
and whether we're we we also know that
there's to teach your shortage committee
which we have here and that bill is put
forth by Senator Khan last year was it
um yeah and and and Ruth is now Senator
Ward is now chairing that and we're
noticing that we have a shortage to
teachers in science mathematics special
education and the math and the technical
areas and and that's where it really
identifies itself and so now we're
looking at uh looking at our curriculum
and we don't have the we we can only set
up guidelines or Frameworks on this
level it's up to the locals to to adopt
and put their curriculum together but we
want to today try to lean a little bit
into what's going on at the higher
education post-secondary levels in terms
of teacher preparation and uh are the
what being taught there does it align
with uh what we're doing in our schools
um it's been a number of years since
I've been there so I really can't I
don't have that information then that's
why we've invited you know Brian and
Tanya here today
and and Dr Rubinstein and Shannon also
from the community college system I know
you're engaged with teacher preparation
programs as well and and those tie in
with what we have been discussing in
past years when we were looking at HP
1530 where the associate's degree just
goes on and and and counts as those
first two years you're coming as a
junior uh we identified 30 major areas
in which that it works and so I I
believe in future meetings we will be
discussing that in terms of is it
working uh
I don't know I've heard some places
where it hasn't uh especially when we're
dealing with going from into an
engineering a very specific a degree
area at the four-year level but getting
back to the curricular areas I'd like to
now just open it up if we can please if
we can get an overview of of the teacher
preparation programs that are leaning
towards certification and our stay here
K through 12 pre-k through 12.
as well as you know
identifying specifically at what is
being done at the elementary levels uh
in some of this uh I've met recently
with teachers out in various school
districts in several districts now and
it seems that there's a almost a
disconnect between what's going on at
the secondary level versus what's going
on at the elementary level as far as
working and aligning together
and what the expectations are so
um what you're doing at the
post-secondary level in terms of
preparing our elementary teachers trying
to get into some of the areas like are
the skills and now it's being taught
aside from the pedagogical type methods
uh
I know at the secondary level if you're
going to be teaching social studies you
have a background in history or
government Civics economics geography
however in the elementary
how well prepared are these teachers for
the content
I know of methods you know I brought in
one of my old books which I had for the
teaching of social studies that was
written in 1984 and of course that was
the second edition I had the first
edition which was written around 1970
and
um that was all you know how to teach it
didn't say what to teach
and so maybe those are some of the
things we can address a little bit in
and I don't know who would like to go
first Tanya or Brian go for it um okay
so for our elementary education I can
speak specifically for Keene State one
of the things that um we have kind of
held on to it is a public liberal art so
we really value the liberal arts and all
of our elementary majors are dual Majors
that means that they major in elementary
education and they have a liberal arts
major and we kind of guide them to
certain areas sometimes we allow them to
kind of have a little freedom but that
gives them a little more content and
also connection to some other um some
other courses people course offering
some of those things that broaden their
knowledge in addition to that we require
two math courses that are specific for
our elementary and students to build
that content
we also guide them when it comes to our
ISP because we have the our general
curriculum is an ISP the integrative
studies program where they have to take
courses in the Ia which is Arts IH which
is Humanities in which is Natural
Science and is which is social science
and then the last one is integrated
studies so a lot of times we'll guide
them as they're choosing courses for
example a great IH is one of the history
courses that we recommend our students
because it also helps prepare them for
the practice to multi-subject tests and
there's a bunch of other courses like an
in there's a phenomenal science course
that the students really enjoy so we try
to guide them in courses that we think
would benefit them as they continue on
in education in addition to that we
have set up our methods where Elementary
methods one is kind of an integrated
it's eight credits where it's a mixture
of content pedagogy and time in the
field and methods one is focuses on
literacy and on um so and and social
studies and our methods too focuses on
math and science so they get another
chance where they're taking the content
that they've learned learning how to
teach it and then applying it in the um
schools that they're placed uh and then
we have lesson plans that go beyond that
and I should also add I know literacy is
not considered maybe a Content area but
we do have a course that they've taken
that before they enter methods one
because if we didn't then the entire
methods one would just be about literacy
and we don't want to shortchange the
social studies piece in that course so I
mean that's kind of a quick overview of
what our students do but imagine that
second liberal arts that's another 36 to
44 credits and another content area that
they're taking we also encourage our
students to choose as their liberal arts
the English one of the social studies or
math or Sciences because it also opens
them up to the opportunity when they
finish they could switch from a KC k6
licensure to a K-8 with those specific
liberal arts
does that answer is there anything it's
like the quick overview are there any
questions regarding that to where we are
right now
um so Plymouth State University
um some similarities to what happens at
Keene uh so a few things um especially
Elementary education so we have a k6 and
K8 pathway
um so first to clarify that piece the
big difference between k6 and Ka is the
K-8 pathway requires an additional 15
credits
um uh to meet that that's what's
outlined by the New Hampshire 612s all
right so any student that's doing 16 is
doing K8 has to have kind of like that
content specialty area all right in
addition to passing the Praxis too in
that content area for what they're doing
um then across the board
um
I'm thinking about the k6 piece you know
this breakdown between content and
pedagogy
um there is we try to make sure our
students have like they have Elementary
Ed they have multiple math classes
geared towards that there are literacy
courses as well that focuses on the
content piece and then integrated into
that into science and the social studies
piece as well
um similar to we also have with the
content piece um try to ensure that the
students through the general education
program which is 42 to 47 credits
um that they are taking certain classes
as well all right they're going to
really that build up their content
knowledge for the teaching and what's
expected to be taught in the history uh
classroom or science classroom it's
Fourth sixth grade really K through six
as well because as you said is you don't
have the content it's really hard to
teach it all right one of the things
that's really become important in this
part of it is that our students when
they are in their clinical experiences
and they start having clinical
experiences their first year right we've
really embedded that piece so that they
are spending time in classrooms in k6 or
K-8 classrooms and even some of them you
know this is just the elementary level
um really getting a sense of what's
happening in those classrooms so start
thinking about it right it's not just to
wait until the final year this is this
early on the June it starts simple like
a gradual progression they're doing
observation work and then it you know
the expectations go up with each year as
they continue uh that last time being
their junior year the third year they're
implementing lesson plans and then
getting ready our elementary education
students do what we call a year-long
internship whereas in the fall they stay
we want them to see the whole cycle of
the school year so in the fall they're
there for a practicum for one day a week
plus two full weeks and then they stay
with that same teacher through the
spring as well so they get an
opportunity to see that whole scope and
sequence in the classroom that they're
placed in you know and through what we
make sure is we use the 612 standard the
content standards the guide what we do
so that we make sure that our programs
are aligned with the 612 standards for
elementary education and if you take a
look at those there since we're talking
about social studies
um they actually have them here but you
know they outline who I know they
outline the 10 different themes and the
different areas with social studies that
it's expected and we really make sure
that our students have
um that they have that as much as
possible and getting ready I'll say well
representative thank you for being here
I've I've got uh probably three
questions one is um what's the history
of your enrollment
in these programs uh
prior to and current uh also you
indicated that uh the program
development uh is aligned with the
standards uh for this from the state I'd
like to know a little bit more about
that
and find the final question is how do
you get feedback
from uh the students who've gone through
your program
to ensure that the content and the
development of your program is actually
meeting the needs and it's not an ivory
Tower approach uh to uh the the
education of potential teachers but
actually is meeting the actual needs as
they're experiencing them in the field
thank you
okay so let me I'll answer the last one
first and then remind me of the other
two
we do and I and I know um Plymouth does
as well we do Cape accreditation we do
um also a lot of program review we'll
both sit on the council for Teacher Ed
so there's a lot of oversight on the Ed
prep programs at the state level and
then we do the national accreditation
it's another level and the important
thing about the doing the national
accreditation and part of Cape is that
it's not just getting uh surveys and
focus and getting the feedback from the
students in the program part of it is
knowing where your students are going
evaluating the impact that they have on
their classrooms and doing surveys and
focus groups with both completers and
with employers like those who have hired
our students to hear about the impact
that they're having in the classrooms
and that's for all of our programs not
just for our elementary education
programs so there's a lot of oversight
and constant kind of review and this
year we just finished our cape and state
approval this year so one of the things
that we're going to be spending our
professional development we do every
year but this is kind of a significant
year because we just went through it is
to really look back and say what are
changes that we need to make based on
what we hear or what we think
improvements and another piece of that
is we have an educator preparation
advisory committee
and that is where we meet I set up
meetings and we have uh Representatives
on that committee that are cooperating
teachers we have students we have
principals we have superintendents and
the students are both our undergrad and
our grad students and uh some faculty
representation where we bring things
that we're kind of discussing to really
so for example we're reviewing our
clinical and disposition evaluations
those are kind of those unit-wide
evaluations do they have the skills of a
teacher do they have the dis
professional disposition and we share
with them to get feedback once they've
used it does it make sense are there
changes that need to meet does this
reflect what's happening in the schools
and that's just a continuous part of
what the work that we do
and then I think you asked about the um
aligning with the 612s
Brian brought the matrixes that the
state sets up but we have to in all of
our programs this is for all of our
programs and for our unit we create um
cross uh crosswalks that reference the
state standard it references if we have
any Spa like specialized standards the
cape standards or whatever accreditation
all those things across and we align it
with coursework with assignments with
key assessments so that we know where we
are meeting all of those elements that
are covered in the state standards and
we do it by specific programs and then
the Professional Standards as well and
then I think the last question was oh do
you want to add to that before you go
into aeromics okay and then the Roman
Trends across the state is or across the
country
um numbers in the Ed prep have gone down
um I would say the the biggest tip we
saw kind of was in I would say during
covid but one of the things we've
noticed since then the past two years
our numbers have started going up
slightly I would say our elementary
major about 10 years ago it was so large
that about half our graduates wouldn't
even find jobs now we're at the point
where our you know graduating class this
year most of them already have job
offers our numbers have come to a
healthy level where they are finding
jobs as they leave but our elementary Ed
which is always the largest program is
growing the secondary we've been kind of
consistent it's dropped a little our
English and our social studies tend to
stay healthy our math and our science
are the ones that fluctuate and I will
be honest that because of our numbers in
the science and the amount of work it
takes to do that was the one that was
put on hold by the institution not by
something I want to do and I would love
to bring it back but science which is a
critical shortage it is hard and I think
I mean that's something we can talk
about in the teacher shortage like that
recruitment piece or how do we get more
students in teacher Ed but does that
answer all three thank you
foreign
and um
Tanya I wonder well I want to sort of
poke on something that that you just
noted when when answering someone else's
questions but uh they said what changes
do we need to make based on what we're
hearing
and I wanted to sort of tie that back to
what Rick was saying I'm sorry I'm being
sort of just
um you know easy going here it's Friday
it's Friday yeah it's Friday yeah
um but um
tied back to what what Rick said at the
top of the meeting which which um uh
which and I and I and I think you so it
sort of went to over the last decade
we've seen a decline in in student
performance in um in maths skills and
and I guess I'm I I'm just taking the
taking it at face value right now it's
not looking at any information in front
of me on it but have you been able to
identify whether whether that that lack
of student outcomes is tied to
I mean a foundational math advanced math
and then and then what are the causes of
it
uh addressed by improved instruction or
improved curriculum or some combination
of both and what are you finding and how
is that feeding back into
um you know the sort of what we're
hearing and what changes we need to make
so I think
the thing is is that in schools today
it's hard because it's not just about
academics I think teachers today have
have to wear many hats and I think a lot
of the social emotional the mental
health and all these other pieces and
covet take an impact on their ability to
kind of um because they have to focus on
those pieces to get to the academic so I
think there's a lot more factors that
come into play when you look into the
test scores when it comes to math I
would say that I think teachers amazing
and doing the best that they can but
some of it is more than just their
training it's not about that it's about
all the other factors coming in and
making sure that they have the resources
but I think another piece is is that we
train and I'm speaking Brian for you two
we teach our teachers not only the
content but the pedagogy and the lesson
planning and knowing your students and
how to create lessons and how to engage
them and a lot of schools rely on box
curriculums and and that is sometimes
limiting to these teachers that have
been trained to really meet the needs of
students and create lessons that would
engage them and challenge them meet them
where they are differentiate so I think
that is something that is not about what
we do but something that is a larger
discussion to have
and we do take the feedback that they
say about the um you know what's
happening in the schools and some of
those things but one of the things that
I noticed and this is me speaking for
our program is about seven eight years
ago we used to have a math like pre-map
test to get into the first Math course
for our LED and I noticed the number of
our students that would fight and avoid
taking it and delay it and cause them to
bet you know either not do well or then
be delayed in taking those math courses
which would affect their progression so
I met with the math department I talked
to students about it and they're like oh
I hate math I hate math I said you're an
LED teacher you can't hate math we all
love math but it created another barrier
and so we met with the math department
and we said this math test is causing uh
you know students that come in with this
negative view of math before they even
engage so we removed that pre-mat test
and so when our students come in now
they go they can take the math 171 and
math 172 and take it and it has changed
the way our students see math they are
now doing better in getting through the
math and progressing in our program
they're also
um doing more successful in their
attempts when it comes to taking the
Praxis core in math and the practice two
in math which wasn't before because now
they don't have that barrier and then
the last thing was they were doing the
the successes of students in different
various math courses our iql thing and
they realized that our students that did
this math 171 math 7172 a lot of
students were not doing well in the
psych research method like the site
stats class that they had but they
realized that the most successful
students in those courses were the
elementary ed students because they had
the two math classes before and they
ended up doing really well in that so
our students have started to change it
change the way that they see and they
engage in math so and I think those are
things that sometimes we have to realize
that
the way we teach or the tests that we
put on students create barriers to them
um and uh so and I think that's where
the feedback came into play and started
changing the culture particular
follow up on that and so so you've
removed that barrier
um um your um your your students in the
in the teacher training programs have
now now enter these math programs
without sort of the anxiety of having to
to take a high pressure test beforehand
and and
how has that then changed their
attitudes towards or their their feeling
towards math and how they project that
on
um
they're young students that they that
they eventually are in front of we have
a lot less of students saying oh my God
I don't want to do this math or I don't
like this math and I will also say our
math department has done a really good
job that the people who teach it are
either teachers themselves or in our
secondary yet so they're really helping
students enjoy and understand the
concept so a lot of them actually leave
the math class saying I actually
understand this so it's really changed
we see a lot less negativity towards
math and I also remind students I was a
special educator and I was somebody who
I liked math I I was I got math but when
I went to teach special ed in high
school they said what do you want to
teach and I didn't want to teach math
because I understood math I wanted to
teach the English because that is where
students said well I didn't get this I'd
be like oh I understand let's go through
this let's break this down so I also try
to remind the students sometimes what
you think is a struggle becomes your
superpower as a teacher and so we've
changed the conversations that we have
with students who are going into teacher
Ed to change change that mindset and to
really enjoy and realize that being an
elementary a teacher specifically you
have to enjoy and engage in all the
content and I think that's one of the
reasons that we switched to that
integrated of really kind of allowing
them to spend more time on that content
and a concept and practicing and
enjoying and being in the classroom for
that
a number of years ago and Shannon and
Mark you might engage a little bit in
this
um we we heard from the community
college system now this is going back to
when uh Paul leather was Deputy
Commissioner of Education
that 60 of our kids coming out of high
school going on to the community college
system and I I never got that from the
college presidents because they they
said we don't have remedial call we we
start right off right out of the gate
but uh Shannon you were very honest
saying that of those 60 percent uh
requiring some kind of uh now we don't
want to use the term remedial I know
you've changed the game a little bit but
of those 60 50 never graduated with an
Associates due to the fact that the it
was math
and so evidently there we weren't
sending students to higher ed
well-prepared in that subject area and
so you were having to do the job of
maybe what perhaps K-12 should have been
doing
I mean we we could give data on that
just our I mean to practice course
scores like our students like we look at
practice core score data which is
basically a task based on 8th through
10th grade yeah High School
um and then students that are Pass rates
like it takes students some students
multiple times to pass this test you
know this stuff that would be considered
with medial workers things it's based on
you know what should have already been
taught what they should have had coming
in
so how are we communicating that down to
the high schools and to the local school
districts that we're having this issue
and I don't know where it whether it's
getting better with what you're doing
um well as you know we have moved it
from the kind of old old model of
remedial education into what we call
co-requisite remediation for Math and
English where that's needed and that's
putting the students directly into a
college credit Math course but giving
them specific supports they need in
areas where they're not uh you know
where they're maybe not prepared
um and and that has that has improved
their the outcomes for those students
um in terms of the students that go on
that that persist and go on to graduate
so once they get to us that's that's
what we're doing to kind of improve
um and improve improve their outcomes
as as you as you know we used to have a
program called the math learning
communities which was a partnership with
the high schools that helped to embed
the competencies within High School Math
that would prepare students before they
left high school for college level math
and thanks to well there's funding
currently in House Bill 2 now to revive
that program
which you know we certainly consider
it's very promising numbers coming to
you Shannon that you're still having
these students coming from secondary
education to you that need the
co-requisite type instruction
I I don't have the the numbers
um off the top of my head but you know
I'm sure there are still students coming
to us that need that need that
Senator dalessandro
thank you Mr chairman a couple things
with regard to your your robot what's
the percentage of bid that are in the
enrollment
it's gonna say I don't have that data
but
um it's more balanced in our secondary
okay you know our music and our PE our
elementary still is predominantly female
but we are getting more males that are
coming into Elementary education so and
when they do come we're like please
um so I mean I don't have the exact
numbers but it's still consistent I
don't know the same for you same thing
um we have we see more men in social
studies in physical education health
education less so although even this
year's cohort you know I think out of 30
something we have five males there so
um and we always try to not to because I
was a male Elementary School teacher too
so
um but you know we do try to pair them
up with other male you know we try to
support that and try to encourage that
as much as possible because I think it's
really important to have
um as much as possible
um
for the first question
sorry
in the past keyed state has had an
association with the parking Verde
school I represent that area
um well we have different levels of
partnership so usually
the partnership schools we have
presently and this is especially I said
right before like around covid a lot of
the partnership schools are in the
Monadnock region but we do do a lot of
Outreach especially with our students
and student teaching if some of them
need to we have had students in the
Manchester area that we've had in
Londonderry we've had up to Concord a
lot of times it's but but we base it on
supporting the student if they need to
live at home and then our faculty will
travel to do the observations at those
schools I do know that Steve bagai does
a lot of um out we reach and partnership
work he's our grad coordinator in the
Varney School and some of those in
Manchester okay yeah do you have
anything with us Yes actually you have a
wonderful partnership with Northwest
Elementary School
um Shelley the principality is fantastic
and it varies how many interns we have
there or clinical experiences but we've
been working with them uh probably for
the past five years now and it's been a
great experience for our students in the
school and also working with that school
Northwest is a very successful school
I'll be duplex was the principal there
he was one of my students when he was in
high school and one for the I have eight
minority schools in the district and I
represent Hispanic and black represent
the majority of students of those
schools
how how do you face that in terms of
your preparation knowing knowing that
um I think we tried to what we try to do
is give our students a wide range of
field experiences which is why they
started so early so we have
um Manchester we don't work as much in
Manchester because it's over an hour for
a student to get there and
transportation issues are improved with
the challenge
um with that but what we've tried to do
is that we try to prepare our students
you know we work in in a wide range we
work in the Franklin School District
which is has been some challenges we
work with Laconia we work right in our
backyard SAU 48 and our goal is to have
students work in a variety of different
environments to help prepare them using
embed in those clinical experiences and
then tying them together
um with what they do in the coursework
our faculty members spend time at
schools as well and I think what we're
really trying to do you know some of the
earlier questions I heard was we want
there to be that connection to what
they're happening happening in schools
is connected to what they are preparing
in that coursework
and I would say for us that
we do give multiple experiences and
we're very cognizant of grade levels and
experiences Middle High School to give a
variety but Monadnock region doesn't
have the same level of diversity but if
it was up to me I keep joking with the
school I said I would love to get a bus
and train someone to be a bus driver so
our students could make those
connections and experiences and if we
have students at the student teaching
who want to be placed in some of those
schools we we happily support those
Endeavors we did get a couple of um we
are just in the midst of a search we had
a donor a couple years ago that wanted
to bring some more urban experience into
for Keene State so we've been searching
for a candidate that can come for two
years that will bring recent Urban
experience and to Keene State College to
bring that to all of our students but
also in hopes that it will make
connections so our students can start
going and spending time in some other
schools in the region as well my last
question is
we now have social workers in our
elementary schools but particularly
Northwest which is uh as you know
there's great variety of Northwest pack
of early gosh so you go right through
the situation
it um these social workers are very busy
it that that the poor classroom teacher
has to deal with with these situations
and our kids are 80 sometimes 90 free
reduced my solution you know the
economic environment they're coming from
how do you how do your people handle
that kind of a situation
you how do you prep a foreign in other
words well it's
it's interesting because we have schools
in Keene one of the elementary schools
has over 82 of them over 80 percent
um low SES pre-reduced lunch so some of
the the especially the economic um
diversity is relevant we also have
students and our one of our methods one
Partnerships is with Hinsdale and I
don't know if you know Hinsdale but it's
rural
yeah that's right and so they're going
into the the other it's like you know
what you it's like the complete opposite
but it has a lot of this like low SES
Transportation some of those so the part
of our job is to not only just put them
in the schools and I'm sure I know you
do this as well is that we really think
it's important that our students
understand the community that they're
working with and all the things that are
coming into it and then by having two
different so we might have a methods one
in Hinsdale and methods two the students
might be up in Keene which is a very
different Dynamic uh financial support
by schools SAU structure all those
things are very different for the
students to to kind of tease an
experience
you're welcome
yeah as a follow-up does Lou's question
what's the diversity makeup of your
student population who are becoming
teachers
say
University is the fact that we can say
it's been for a long time over 40
percent uh first generation college
students so we have a lot of students
that they are the first and navigating
that piece we also and these aren't all
documented
um you know they don't always like to go
to the office and disabilities but we
tend to have over 40 percent of students
that have disabilities also come to
Keene State so we do have a lot of
diversity and there's if you come and
actually I don't have the demographics
but if you went on our website I know
our Factbook that was presented they
have been doing a lot more Outreach to
bring more diversity to Keene State
because it is needed to represent what
is beyond just the Monadnock region so
and with that we are very active and I
know I'm speaking I'm saying me but I
know we do it you do the same thing that
is why faculty we're always there on
um you know open house things admitted
student days when students come to tour
because that that is a way to kind of
expand that diversity when families come
what you just commented on but I think
at the end of the day of our students
who have been preparing to become
teachers would probably identify as
white or Caucasian yeah very high
numbers yeah on that I think it's
important to note that because
our students our population is becoming
much more diverse and it's not just in
Manchester or Nashua and so that would
be a concern that I have and I I deal
with City year in Manchester and they
have a very diverse Corps member and the
superintendent there's always trying to
hire some of those students after they
finish their core experience to be
teachers there in Manchester so I would
just encourage you to do whatever you
can to have a greater diversity from a
minority standpoint in your student
population because we need those and
kids need to see those people who look
like them teaching them we agree I'd
like to get onto just a little slightly
different topic when we had a bill in
here the other day in its SB 216. we
were talking about Civics education and
we got in the other areas of the social
studies as well and one of the questions
which was asked and this happened to be
asked of Megan Tuttle who is the
president of Nea and her children in
fact are in public school right now and
we're talking about what do we usually
do in social studies at the fourth grade
level in this state
I know in May and I it was always main
studies
and here it's New Hampshire studies as
well and but what Megan said to me was
kind of you know it didn't surprise me
it was that well their their New
Hampshire studies program is probably
going to be the visit to the Capitol
Building period that's it
no more now and no less that's it
um I'm I'm really a little bit concerned
now and another thing that came up in
that conversation was that we're
assessing on the Statewide assessment
Reading Writing mathematics language
arts area and science not every year
social studies is not assessed at all
so I guess one way of saying what takes
the back seat in the car
um you're not going to be measured on
this subject uh you're not going to be
held accountable for this subject what
do we do to ensure that
um and I'm getting slightly into this
area of social studies what can I do to
ensure that it's taught and I I know
that your their your higher education
and are you so from the teacher prep
side are you teaching and and teaching
that content about New Hampshire uh
about our Civics about our you know our
geography Etc
um and you mentioned earlier that the
you know there's a number if you're k
through eight you have to number other
credits subject areas
um
I I'm I'm just concerned that are we are
we employing teachers that have the
I know they're coming back in in their
in the in education and they're finding
that there's this this there's this book
that says here's our curriculum if they
even have a book anymore and and uh
that's it it's already established so
you have to teach and I also understand
all the other issues we have a lot of
mental health issues going on a lot of
time being absorbed it's got to come
from something at school day five and a
half hours of instructions that's it at
Max you have recesses in there too and
others so
um where should we go you know when we
I don't know I'll just share anecdotally
um
we find so in preparing our teachers to
be k-6 teachers or Ka in their
internship placements and the clinical
placements I would just concur with you
that our students have fewer
opportunities to teach science and
social studies in those classrooms
unfortunately I think you're right is
that a lot of school schools that I
visited and spend time with and not but
you see more schools pushing
um reading pushing math extended times
at the expense of social studies and or
science being taught this is anecdotally
but so I don't have an answer for you
but just to say I think what then though
in terms of our team you know even the
students as we prepare them
we're a big believer that the clinical I
think like anything by practicing is how
you get better right but if you have
fewer opportunities because you see it
you know less so I think it is something
that
um
I don't have the magic answer to it but
it definitely we've seen that yeah
um and anecdotally it's it's interesting
because
and and Keenan I can speak for Keen my
children participated in um third grade
they do a lot with um the the keen and
they have a day where all and I get to
see it outside my office where all the
third grades are visiting and they're
walking around downtown they're visiting
Wyman way and they're going here and
there they come have lunch in the dining
hall and so they have it and you see it
and the students are enriched with it
and it was interesting I was talking to
a teacher uh last year and I said if you
need help we have students they will
happily walk so we're talking about
plans of getting our students to help
support that and to have you know then
they get to experience it as well and
and on the other side of it I have a son
in ninth grade right now and he's taking
a street Law class right at the high
school and at first I was you know as an
elective and he is loving it and the
things that he is learning so I think
that there's opportunities and I think
there's want but I think the stress of
trying you know this the test testing
you have to meet this in literacy and
this is math and this is your school is
going to be judged and you it puts a
stress that causes science and social
safety be pushed on the side but if you
think about it and I was reading through
the bill
there's a lot of ways that we can
include even the Civic and education
that is part of the social emotional
let's talk about Community how do we
create a community how do we structure
it how do we listen to all voices that
is also part of social emotional
learning so I think that there's things
that could be done and I do know and I
know um that you know we do in our
programs we teach our students what they
need to do I can tell you specifically
in our social studies Ed our secondary
program they do a lot in preparation
there's a reason why they don't have to
just major in history they can major in
sociology or political science and all
those because those come in but they
still take courses to meet the
competency but one of the things that
our students can major in is Holocaust
and genocide studies not only for our
secondary Social Studies they can do
that as their liberal arts but our
elementary Ed and those allow them to
learn this content and ways of teaching
and engaging and stuff that they can
bring bring into the classroom so I
think we are doing the preparation piece
in which teaching them how but I think
that part of it is entering a school
there's also all those other things that
they're they're coming into conflict
with but I will say I was meeting with
the student yesterday I was telling them
I was meeting about our courses for next
year but she was telling me that she had
just gotten back from Hinsdale and she
was teaching she taught a lesson on the
three branches of government she was in
a fourth grade class and I was like okay
look they are teaching some social
studies
um but I think also having our students
in there because they have to teach a
letter so many literacy and so many
social studies in a way it infuses it
into the schools and maybe it changes it
yeah
I just thought it should have been
um we're really trying to teach our
students how to integrate right how do
you work together when you're integrated
because given the limited amount of time
so a lot of social how do you kind of
integrate um your Ela and your social
studies together and really giving them
those skills
um going forward so that's being a big
part uh recognizing The Limited you know
I can't control what's in the school day
and what's taught in the school day but
what we can control is make sure our
teachers are prepared our students are
prepared to maximize that time when
they're teaching and think about
or
where are you finding that your teachers
are going to teach
are they going to teach in public
schools
private schools
Etc and the second question is
um how long do they stay there
are you finding uh after the fifth year
second year they find this is not what I
want to do as a profession for a number
of different reasons so the issue of the
Fallout once they start their career
what happened what's interesting is that
one of the things we did with our survey
we do a completer survey and as I
mentioned with cape it's like five years
and one of the things that we ask our
student is are you currently teaching in
the area that you're like you know
licensed in our program and are you
teaching private or public and I would
say most are still teaching but um some
of them may not be teaching you know
like we might have had an LED that did
special ed and now they're doing Special
Ed but not Allied some of those pieces
but
I would say less than that but I don't
think and I was at the teacher shortage
last year or last fall
a lot of them aren't staying in New
Hampshire unless they're from New
Hampshire and it's because of the costs
um we just the they have loans a lot of
them are going home to live at home to
start working they have connections in
schools and like we have for example we
have a graduate of ours she's taught now
in Swansea which is the net you know
right next to Keene for three years this
is her third year she came straight out
of our elementary ad has been teaching
LED in the course place that she did her
methods one and then there's student
teaching so she stayed she's leaving
because she can't afford the the pay her
apartment anymore because housing she's
not being paid enough to be able to live
in the area too so she's going back home
so that she can live with her boyfriend
at shares costs so these are factors
that affect them and I even said to them
last uh fall I said I would love you
guys are always welcome I know they come
talk to our students and ask them I mean
it's really fascinating to ask them like
what is it that you're going to do or
what are your plans but most of them I
will say want to do public school
because that's what they're trained in
and that's what we have them um you know
in other placements or public schools
uh we find about 50 of our students stay
in New Hampshire
how many are in a class you know uh
sure if so we're gonna go undergraduate
so if I'm gonna stay just undergraduate
um per student uh we've probably run 100
to 110 completers each year that's an
education that is in the teacher
certification program social studies
Elementary Ed right around there
um special education so it's about 50
stay in New Hampshire 50 leave so you're
already looking at that number that's
here at Plymouth and then I think those
are great questions you're asking and
we're trying to follow those I think one
if I could so we are research our data
is based on two things surveys with
students and the New Hampshire
Department of Education educator search
database if I could make a plug for
something I think this would be
something that would be great that maybe
ihis could partner with the Department
of Education to get the data even better
because if individuals change names or
you know it's easy to to lose some of
that because I think these are really
important questions how you know two
years later are they still teaching
three years and I will tell you I see a
smaller trickle of folks that are
finishing their student teach and be
like I don't want to teach you know they
did a good job but just decide right now
I don't want to do this and I think you
know and I can't give you concrete
numbers and we're trying to measure this
too and I think this is I think this is
helpful because Nationwide teacher
shortage Trends is looking at this you
know it used to be that typically you
knew someone's going to become a teacher
you had three to five years before they
might bail now they're talking about one
to two years they're bailing out and I
think that would be really fascinating
as not just at Plymouth but I think you
know across the whole if you know and
I'd be happy to work the Department of
Education on this or figure out it's
like okay how many individuals are
getting New Hampshire teaching license
and then quit and you know one year
later or two years later and then if you
really want to put a spotlight because I
can say those folks that are quitting
what were they doing are they graduating
from a New Hampshire school are they
graduating from um a state-based
licensing plan are they graduating from
out of state you know what I mean like
start looking at those different factors
but that's a lot of time but I think
that starts it I think to get the
answers to things I think you have to
have data that really is painting an
accurate picture not just anecdotally
but
and but I I don't know what happens
going forward because I've definitely
seen the past couple years like with
covet a different thing definitely a
number starting to trickle up who just
saying that they're not going into
teaching after graduating
whether that's going to subside again or
keep going you know that's that's a
really important question to answer
um how where do they come from how many
are out of state students how many are
in-state students when they start as
freshmen
what percentage in the education
programs yes
I'd have to I I don't want to speak I'd
have to go look at that data exactly I
think I was gonna say about half for New
Hampshire we get a lot from Connecticut
yeah do you get a lot from Connecticut
no we got a lot from Massachusetts we
get some from Mass but we get a ton from
like Connecticut's a big one some from
Maine some for mass and some from New
York but um I would say the biggest
pockets are New Hampshire and
Connecticut
so if you have approximately 50 coming
in
but 50 leaving
it kind of balances doesn't it it does
um it does but it's
um I do feel like that there's a lot um
like I
like SAU 29 which is a huge SAU right
there in the bananica region they're
always like oh but we want your students
to stay and stay in keen and I was like
I would love them to but they're not
staying there because our number from
that area is lower they're coming from
other areas in New Hampshire so yes
they're going back to those areas in New
Hampshire but it may not support the
Monadnock region as much I have noticed
though our students who are doing our
one-year special ed Masters because
they're one year employed in the school
those students we tend to have a higher
percentage staying after graduation but
I think it's because they're employed
and they're kind of become invested in
okay
well thanks thanks Rick and um uh the
the question I'm going to ask is it's
not it's it's not a political question
but but I think it's it's it's
appropriate at this given our where we
are in the discussion but I'm wondering
how your teacher training programs have
adapted to the um the relatively new New
Hampshire band Concepts uh law
you mean the divisive concept correct we
teach our students about it and and
Empower them to know how to navigate it
and I would say specifically
um our social studies Ed and and
ironically I should have brought my
faculty member from that he does a lot
on that um because the social studies
tends to be the area where um that would
come into play I think there's just a
lot of stress on teachers in the schools
they feel that they are being watched I
think our student teachers have said
that they're they're like can I do this
can I do that and it's just navigating
reminding them that you know it's about
the facts and this is what the law says
we've also had professional development
we have the Southwest Center they've
done a lot of webinars where they've
brought in lawyers or Dottie Morris has
talked about it or you know we have
speakers that support not just our
students but also the community and that
teachers we offered them last year for
free just so teachers and principals and
superintendents could could engage in it
be able to ask questions
so yeah does that answer
right right so so I I guess what I'm
what I'm hearing is that is that yes the
programs have adapted yes in in in light
of this this change in um in law and um
and I uh
yeah I mean I think that's that's it and
then do do the students do your students
have have like sort of a clear
understanding of of of where those
you know where the the edge of the road
is on
on this because I hear that that's a
sort of a common concern well I think it
is I think that they I think we're clear
about where the edge is and what they
can and can't do but I think that
students feel concerned like can I do
this or can I say that or you know what
I mean that because their intent they're
taught um and it's interesting that we
were talking about Civic engagement you
know they're taught all these ways to
bring in books especially for young
children and all these activities and
now they're going in and they're like
is this okay to do even though it's good
teaching and it is okay to do but it's
made them kind of self-aware
um and and I think that they're getting
it not so much for our end but from when
they're in the schools you know we even
had a property and teacher was like no
you need to give me your lesson plan
three weeks in advance and I need to
post it and the student's like wait
three weeks you know I can't do that I'm
a you know a method student so I think
sometimes
I don't know I think the politics of it
sometimes get in the way of the the best
practices of teaching set up
a good way of saying
can I talk for a second about
integrating and or embedding uh content
into another subject area or skills and
knowledge
um that that's a concept or a process a
teaching method that's been around for
years uh we had thematic reading
programs where you bring in historical
fiction into the the reading program and
and it was quite effective do you and
your higher education teacher prep
programs uh teach how to embed where to
embed and give suggestions as to how to
do it I see that's part of the Civics
bill here in the elementary schools and
sometimes I think that's a little scary
in the fact that and I'm an advocate of
doing it but it's also a way of saying
there's not going to be any
accountability for it either and it's
just not going to be taught whereas if
there's a course like we do at the high
school level there's a course in it
that's going to be taught
hopefully
um but when you say embed it it becomes
part of that language arts reading class
and if you have a person that's a
reading language arts person perhaps
they don't you know that's not what
willing to embed a social studies
concept into that class
um then it's not going to be taught
so how do we how do we prepare teachers
to to go ahead and embed and integrate
properly
so for elementary education what we're
actually doing is our faculty are
modeling that we've actually adopted the
program they changed kind of the course
sequence and what they're doing so the
faculty or team teaching and working
together and showing how to embed
um that kind of having a user integrated
methods course where it's not just
saying oh this is how you teach social
studies this is how you teach Ela
they're actually doing it all together
so that they are modeling what needs to
happen the work the students are a part
of that and that then they can take that
knowledge this is while they're in that
one year practicum a one-year internship
with a practicum in the fall then they
have the opportunities to apply it while
they're there
um so you're right there's no the the
best way I think is to model it to the
practice you almost practice what we
preach and that's what we're focused on
doing the elementary Ed level um so that
our graduates are more prepared to go
into a school situation where maybe this
due to schedule whatever out they don't
have as much time as you would like with
some of these different but how can they
think I just said how can they work
together
um to make sure that the students um at
all grade levels are having social
studies and having science content yeah
and I would just add to that that by the
model that Brian's talking about that we
also do too with the social studies in
literature uh the ELA and then we have
um the science and math but it also is
another way that as these schools are
you know taking some of the science of
math out we're saying no look if you put
these together you bring it in like why
would you separate math and science or
you know social studies you know bring
these pieces in so that they're they get
to see these Concepts through multiple
ways or lenses or any of those things
and and that's where you know social
studies think about I had a my daughter
was telling me a sixth grade you know
like they they had debates and then they
did a vote and they did this democracy
and so it is all kind of you know
embedded in it and it was was actually
sorry it was when she was in fifth grade
she's in sixth grade now but they
integrated and I think that you're
seeing more and more teachers and
unfortunately I think it's more like
fourth fifth grade that they do it it
needs to start lower but I think that
there are some really good teachers and
part of the things that we do in teacher
prep is that we don't just say oh you
want to volunteer to be a cooperating
teacher we don't do that we also screen
because we want our students to be
placed purposefully that we are looking
for teachers that have had the years and
they're they're willing to embed and to
work with our students to provide these
okay
along those lines thanks Rick
one of a very successful integration
that that actually we saw at nhti was uh
was uh with uh with mindful
Communications uh it started out as a um
I think as a as an as a program in in
English
right right and and then was later
integrated in with with a lot of the
engineering curriculum and and others
and I've heard great really really
strong things and I was wondering if
maybe Mark and Shannon could could talk
a little bit about that and whether or
not that could also have
um have you know positive results at the
um primary and secondary level too
I don't know how much I can really talk
about that in detail but I think it's um
it started out as almost like a
um
I won't say professional development but
it's sort of an optional thing that that
students and faculty could could look at
um and has become something that they've
integrated I think into Health our
health programs too where people will be
Healthcare practitioners working with
others which is a can be a stressful
thing um so yeah I think it's become a
much more broadly used
anything further and just wondering if
that that's something that that might be
considered that is some of our you know
primary consecutive
I think it um I do know like at King
State and I'm sure Plymouth there are
mindfulness classes we have meditation
courses we have yoga we have all these
things that we allow our college
students to think about but I do think
it's interesting I think for our
elementary Ed and it's not exactly
mindfulness we teach our students um
responsive classroom which is
kind of I guess the elementary of
creating that community and culture and
taking that moment to settle in the
morning and to connect with your peers
and you know get to know each other so
it's kind of that concept that we do uh
teach and it was interesting because I
was at the um the SAU 29 strategic
planning committee last night
um and I was we were talking about the
um social emotional learning but you
know it's really clear in the elementary
and then there's some pieces in the
middle and then it's like what happens
at the high school you know and uh even
the principal said at the high school
it's like either like the mental health
like top tier or at the bottom where
it's like oh okay this is the high
school there's not much in the middle so
it's interesting to me that I almost
wonder if it's not something to really
consider more so for like the Middle
High School where I think some of that
is not stressed as much or included in
the teaching practices so it is
are all elementary teachers required to
take a methods course in social studies
yeah yes they are both of our programs
though do it as a larger methods where
it has like social studies and something
else but it is you you have to have the
um method social studies science math
and literacy so it is part of the
standards to cover those
so when when did it change when I went
to school get my elementary ticket
I teach a course in math methods of math
math is a language art methods of
cursive methods of social studies and
science they're all separate and
and I you know I I think they were there
you know there was some repetition of
course
studies I really remember because I got
into some good content I loved it and
they do and we do the integrated too
because what happens with our elementary
specifically in methods one they're out
in the field so methods one because it's
eight credit is eight to noon
um every Monday through Thursday and
they are they have two days of content
so 18 in two days in the field so the
goal is to really kind of balance that
they get that content piece that you're
talking about but they also get to have
that like needed time where they're kind
of extended time in the school to really
kind of get to know it and then when
they get to methods two and they're
doing the science and math they're in
the schools either Monday or Wednesday
from eight to three and then their
contents taught um and then they have a
time in the beginning but then they come
to campus on Friday for a half day so I
think the reason for us we made the
change is that we wanted to have more
integration more time in the school
where they can make the connections
because it is hard if you just do social
studies and you you go to do a placement
they may not be teaching social studies
when you have them in the school so by
having these extended it allows them to
kind of see several things being taught
and teach throughout the day versus just
for a smaller time I don't know if it's
similar we had exactly the setup you
described Elementary education until
about 2019 or 2020 we had a three credit
course in each of those so it's 12
credits total part of why we made that
change was feedback listening to
feedback you know what was happening
from our alumni listening to feedback
what was happening at schools is saying
that
um if it was we really had a focus on
the integration of these so that's why
we made so it's the same number of
credit hours in this in the field but
now they just took this into an
integrated methods course to say across
the board and say um you know so still
12 credits total that they have
um now they are just they're doing the
content piece as well but they're really
they're we're not just looking at Social
Studies alone because we're not looking
at science alone they're taking they
still learning how to teach those but
they're also really learning how can we
embed these together in a good
elementary school classroom
um and that's our goal and that's what
we're you know trying to prepare them
for the challenge becomes is what
setting they go into after they graduate
from us right in terms of how much of
the school curriculum is dictated how
much flexibility they have you know
those are other pieces you know the
puzzle there but we're trying as much as
possible to prepare our students so that
they they are ready to integrate and
teach
um all those content areas in elementary
education
it generates some concern to me that
years ago we had allocated so many
minutes per per week to be taught in
certain subject areas
yeah that that went by the boards and I
understand why but it also though
guaranteed that those courses were being
taught
now we don't have that and there's I
don't think there's any guarantee and
after hearing some people speak and
hearings here I'm not so sure that we
are teaching social studies the way we
should be teaching it so the kids are
coming knowledgeable and knowing New
Mexico is not part of Mexico
um
you used to be a social studies teacher
um God support me on this
I taught social studies at kid in high
school in Conway New Hampshire
and then at Bishop Bradley High School
it'd be interested New Hampshire it's a
different world
I mean I go to I take I don't want to
take time because we get the other
things yeah
um I visit my schools I visit every
school in my district every year
and basically I I visit fourth grade
classes because they're taking New
Hampshire history it
the uh
the world is so different
uh
one of the great problems I think is the
constant changing of Administrators
principles of Disappearing at Park
navani we don't have a principal we've
had a principal and leave for what six
months at least so so what's going on in
terms of the operation of of the school
we got a great superintendent I think
she's she's working hard but to get to
the Chairman's situation it's a
different world
and I think we have to we have to adapt
to the to the new world of an old world
guy it's very hard to adapt to the new
world but but you have to do it that's
why I think
trading of
trading is
challenging to say the least recruiting
kids to get into the business is even
more challenging is even more
challenging
I have three kids
none of them
none of them chose education as they're
you know
field of study I just think you have
your challenges you get you have the
enrollment challenge getting kids in
once they're in retaining them getting
getting them to do the kind of teaching
that that makes a lot of sense in terms
of a real educational experience
um
it's just a it's a it's a tough world
yeah it's challenging but you I could I
I don't I don't think I could do it
today
I honestly believe that now I teach at
the college level I teach at city it's
over but I don't I don't know if I could
go back to high school give it given
what's going on
things kind of improve
it
I mean look at what happened at
Portsmouth yet of deviating but look
what happened in Portsmouth yesterday I
got two grandchild
in school enforcement
at 10 o'clock the night before that
college school off the next day because
one of the kids was to kill the assessed
what do you tell your kids about that
about that situation and they apprehend
the kid who was the perpetrator of this
it's a
but we the best we didn't face things
like that and we did
a kid in high school when I was when I
was teaching it's a was the light bus
going to be there to take the kids who
were participating in athletics and give
them give up their ride home at night
different worlds did you have it you
have your challenges
um it
so it's not I subscribe good luck
it
I've got you know Bridge audited
still at school the
little bit challenging but one thing
that that would have one of one of my
grandchild got involved in is the model
you went and that seems that that was I
thought that was great and he's only a
ninth grader
so he's he's in that and he's in the
debating Society they have that code
where are they doing that now okay
so I think those are things into the do
to do worlds and it helps
dude you want to take a little bit here
and talk about your the civics
yeah
thank you uh chairman I
so I I
ooh we're not uh raising means are you
looking for education
this is
um
I would suggest
all the officer probably not lit up but
you go down the hallway uh there's a
smaller office it's usually on either
side where you can see an administrative
assistant in there maybe you can gear
you towards Ways and Means because that
this is education
there is also something going on at the
end of the hallway too all the way at
the end
it suits us
oh that that's a caucus Okay so
you don't want to go in there
yeah
so thank you uh
I'm going to make a leap that the the
bill that representative Ladd has shared
with you is going to pass uh uh Hope
Springs Eternal and
uh that that Civics education is is
something that the public is really
interested in students having greater
exposure so in in looking you know in
the universe of what is available
there's a lot of course material out in
the field uh where people put together
sequences of learning
lessons
so I'm curious with your teacher
training programs
where there is this universe of
materials
but perhaps unvetted at least by
teachers and it's a little hard while
you're flying the plane to read the
instruction manual
um
something that that is uh
within your curriculum to look into
these modules that have been produced
and to critique them
and to have those kinds of discussions
in a classroom so that as students begin
to go out into the field in this
multi-disciplinary kind of method of
language arts and social studies begin
to then say hey look at this one you
know I mean that that they are become a
little bit more of a subject matter or
expert and consultant to teachers not
so thank you I I guess the first I want
to be clear on our social studies they
do a lot with like the grades five
through twelve like the program the
social studies specific content who
would become in social studies I don't
think you're asking about that it sounds
like you want to know more about
elementary education specifically and
the bill is quite particular I mean what
it's trying to do is fit into what the
requirements currently are the occur
we've got a high school requirement
without a a Grade School uh lift to uh
facts and knowledge so this is trying to
to create that that Learning Tree
so I would maybe personally but I well
even our I know social studies faculty
they think this is a great idea you know
in terms of because I think that's one
of the struggles is right is how do you
teach some of this content at seventh
and 8th grade or ninth grade if they
really haven't had it much prior to
right so having Civics having that
earlier on
um so I think it's great and I hope it
does pass
um as uh going forward
um and I I think that you know it's
something that
um at least for Plymouth I think we're
work with is happening with our
elementary education program but I think
even you know with this I think would
just become another step in terms of
um even in implement it even more is
possible
um and then taking a look at the you
know what is available I can't speak I
can you know are not the subject matter
content area for social studies at the
elementary that's a colleague
um you know and that she could speak
more clearly or specifically to certain
modules and what would be the best way
to do it and probably be happy to start
betting that as well
um I would just add to that that um
I always worry when there's modules and
curriculums because
um you don't know who's creating them or
who's putting them out there but when I
think of Elementary and um you know and
I read through the bill and we had a
great chance to talk about it so it got
me thinking about it
is really at the elementary it's not
just only the content but it's teaching
skills it's teaching students how to
have conversations where you're
listening to all the voices and not just
saying my what I think is right is
teaching children how to be critical
thinkers is teaching the children how to
do creative inquiry to say well I wonder
about this how do I find and how do I
know what I'm looking is actually a good
source you know it's teaching students
that there's things that we hear from
the community or on the news or from
family and that our job is to kind of
figure out is this what I believe or do
I just keep saying what I hear and we do
this and if we start this in elementary
imagine how much easier it would be to
have these conversations with students
in college but how do we teach students
that when we decide things that we
decide as a community and why do votes
and voices matter and how does this play
into the larger scheme and then why is
it important important for me to make
sure my voice is heard and and not just
sitting there saying oh why are they
doing this I think there's a lot of
skills that we could teach students at
the elementary level that would really
prepare them not just in the content but
being able to engage with these courses
when they are and especially
specifically you know what you're
talking about here for middle and high
school then they are mature enough and
understand the world a little bit more
and they're ready to engage in those
that learning process those are things
that I don't always think modules think
about and I even had a student
I was teaching the literacy course and
she she was like I'm sorry to ask you a
side question but you know I had the
students he kept saying you know you
know bringing up oh Trump this Trump
that and then the teacher responded and
got in trouble with how she responded
and she said what would you have done I
said don't make it political
why is politics brought you know the
political divide brought into the
classroom let's talk about critical
thinking let's talking about knowing
your sources that's talking about okay
you believe this and somebody believes
that as you know is one better than the
other no but let's listen and then we
can learn how do we create an open space
for a dialogue can happen and she was
like oh that that would have been a much
better approach and so that's where
those conversations happen and if we can
do it in teacher Ed imagine if they
they're the ones going in the classroom
what might happen in the classroom and I
think that's the only thing I think the
idea specific education I agree with you
is really important because we're
preparing Global Citizens We're
preparing students who are ready to
enter the world be part of The Voice
have thoughts know how to critically
think how to find the information but to
do it we need to find ways that it's
scaffold so it's developmentally
appropriate
sorry that was my teacher I'd say
good it's good to hear it
um I made up two possible changes uh on
this I like to just kind of if we could
because you're here Jay and I know
you're very involved with this yes he
does
um first of all uh on on page one we're
talking about courses or course of
instruction
and the Old Law which we have or the
current law says uh one credit or one
half Credit in the two that we have we
have a a one credit course instruction
required for high school graduation in
the United States and New Hampshire
history and one half credit course of
instruction required for high school
graduation in the United States and New
Hampshire government and Civics
um the bill as it's constructed doesn't
mention the word credit
um it talks about a year for a half year
are we wise and dropping out the credit
requirement which is you know basically
reflected in our education rules 306.
uh well I I think I think you're
you make a good observation we do talk
in terms of credits we know that
students have a graduation requirement
it's minimally 22 credits in order to
graduate high school 20. uh and maybe in
other schools is 22. yeah it's 25th or
something that has 27.
it's different around the state but
right okay 20. uh anyway I I think that
is the unit of measurement that 306
makes reference to I understand why
you're why you change it well I'm not
trying to change and trying to retain it
I don't want to see social studies
disappear
from the graduation requirements yes and
it's ought to be a full
credit okay
then then I I have a question on the
bottom there where it says a minus 35 36
37 on page one dedically a dedicated
class time for civics instruction I put
instruction there either way for civics
in each Elementary grade which can be
integrated with other subjects the way
it that the the bills come from the
Senate
it should be shall be taught as part of
social studies are integrated with other
subjects so it shall occur rather than
can
we we fight over little words here but
they mean a lot
yeah
I felt more comfortable with saying it
shall be done
you can't back off from it um
the the other areas
um are more you know this Rick lad
speaking and and that's you know I'm
just but I I put on line three on page
two a half year credit course of
instruction Civics in high school
required that's the discussion we just
had so it doesn't change the intent of
the bill at all
um I think the the line five me I don't
know if this does or not in this section
Civics means a nonpartisan education
program that addresses the following and
then you have those a through d
which you know tried to Define what it
means uh would it be a little bit uh
sharper or you know saying education Pro
committed to the fundamental
responsibilities and principles of
American constitutional democracy that
addresses the following
I don't know if that puts too much in
there or or or it takes takes away if
ads deletes
offered for for a consideration I'm not
asking for somebody to respond right now
but if your thoughts are invited and
then then line 15
I was trying to recall what I've heard a
little bit about some of the teaching of
New Hampshire and Civics and in our
government of New Hampshire
an appreciation for free speech and
civil discourse using historical
references such as how many people know
the first constitution in America was
right here in this state
it was the Pioneer constitution of
January 5 1776.
and it was really hotly debated
um
um in in on line 21
where it says a school district shall
develop an offer the United States of
New Hampshire now we took out government
Civics but that came out from the first
paragraph on on page one there under
item one Roman one
where we're talking about the history
um
and we're talking government
in the Constitutions of the United
States New Hampshire
as part of that course
so I was curious to know whether we
should be also on 1C a school district
shall develop and offer the United
States and New Hampshire history
government and Constitution the United
States and New Hampshire
one year credit course under paragraph
one see this reflects back to paragraph
one
and some of that never came forward the
history never came forward
so we took history out of the law
totally
other than a regular course
which is the first sentence there on one
it took all that other meat out down
below
those are the only changes I put in
um
and and basically to that at all I think
we need the bill absolutely
um
I hope we can get it passed but I'm just
asking if there's any
you know support or criticism or
regarding some of those possible changes
and they're certainly come out of the
education committee when we have that
but coming with higher education people
here you know I'd be curious know any
thoughts
yes Dave
Rick thanks and I think I think a lot of
these a lot of your suggestions here
have uh have some Merit to them and I
think worthy of discussion I think the
the one that that that I'm not following
so much is the one on page one line 25
because I think I think paragraph one
there Roman one really sort of sets
everything up for these half credit and
full credit courses that are talked
about in subsequent paragraphs
um and I think the way it reads in the
bill now there shall be given courses of
instruction in the history government
and then
um one a b and c talk about those
courses some are half credit courses
some are or half your courses some are
full year courses but they're all
courses
um they're not all yeah full year
well there's a lot of ways of teaching
it too you know some schools do it
through one course some do it through
several different courses right but some
integrate it all together but the
graduation requirement right now is a
half credit course at the high school
now it's one and a half no the half
credit course in civics
well I don't have yeah for yes yes I
think that's a that's a graduation
requirement for services a half credit
uh it's government and Civics isn't it
um
it's government and civics
see that we have Civics here we're
taking government out
and putting it up in the other course
because government has to be taught oh
absolutely
so there's going to be a lot of
discussion on this but uh
thoughts yes Dave
um yeah I uh I support I support this
but I want to ask a question of our
field practitioners here
uh we come up with a lot of great ideas
in this legislature
and then we passed them and we pass them
down uh to those who have to implement
this stuff
and so the question I guess I really
have it's a serious question is that as
you as you implement this kind of thing
it's one more it's one more uh issue
that is given to folks like you to have
to develop curriculum Etc I mean
set this aside just for a moment this
issue I mean how do you respond to the
great ideas that we generate here in
this hallowed Place uh and then all of a
sudden say okay do it I mean what how do
you receive this kind of stuff well a
thank you for bringing us here now this
helps
um that we get to be part of the
discussion I think the big thing that
when I talk about things that are past
that impact us it's when things are
passed and they're not
consider the financial implications of
it because sometimes things are passed
and then there's a financial uh burden
that's put on either higher ed or
students or something or for example
this like is there going to be any
financial burden put on schools to be
able to implement this I think knowing
the way that our budgets and the
finances are structured in the state
taking that into consideration is
extremely helpful because sometimes it's
a financial burden that is the biggest
um a barrier for us is that a good way
of saying it I mean for this the
teaching of this implementing it higher
ed we're already doing a lot of this
within our programs I think when I think
of the
um implications I think more on the
schools and um is there going to be
assessments that are required is there
going to be certain curriculum what are
things that are going to be put in
schools that may create a barrier for
this so those are things that go through
my mind and one other thought because I
actually you said something that got me
thinking and I asked Brian you have
middle school is great 678 but the
licensure for social studies is five to
twelve so in some schools our K-8 some
are K to four and then five to eight
there's a lot of variability so I don't
it would be interesting to ask schools
what they consider Middle grades well
they're by Statute uh Middle grades or
anything from grade four
yeah through a possibly even nine to
nine so that's some reason and so yes
there's a lot of and and it's different
all over the state it's just basically
based on population a lot of uh
Geographic issues yep but I just things
to mentioned does that answer your
question
Mr chairman yes uh if I can address a
couple of the points
um
one
relative to uh professional development
it's one of the things that New
Hampshire Civics is fully prepared to do
is use its professional development
summer sessions
to help the teachers you'll also notice
the implementation date here is a year
out so it gives time for that PD
professional development to take place
the the second uh thought is that this
was written by social studies teachers
so the the point about the middle school
and sixth seventh and eighth grade
is that that's when they
introduce Civics instruction uh into a
history like class so it's it's their
input to uh as that that's the age
appropriate uh grades to to have that
over those three years uh the equivalent
of a half credit course or
a semester long
yeah instruction that could be spread
out in several different courses over
over three years the the last thing is
Mr chairman on page two and uh I I
appreciate your historic context for uh
line 16 and and I recall from both the
Senate and the house hearings that the
desire to want to start to add to the
such as uh is that it's it's a limitless
uh uh Clause that uh you know so where
do we stop with such as is but uh I I
understand why you would want to call
reference to that historic note in New
Hampshire's history and uh but again it
it's uh it's something that has come up
in both hearings as to well let's add
this and why are we limiting civil
rights debate to the 50s and 60s and uh
yeah yeah I mean you you heard the
comments uh in your hearing and uh
that's that's the weakness of of trying
to uh
elucidate what the topics uh what the
yeah I I understand totally we don't
want to make a laundry list and I agree
I was only trying to make sure we got
New Hampshire in there somewhere
um
but the interesting part that I noticed
is on the bill that you know the
sections which are maybe cost some time
for professional development don't go
don't occur until July 2024.
which is it which is good that's right
on the last page there in line six
through eight
which is also good but it'd also be good
at the higher education could help us
here you know we've and and Shannon
alluded to the math learning communities
program which we have 38 high schools
which are involved with that and we
uh put two hundred thousand dollars into
the budget in support of of the support
which we get from the community college
system uh in providing professional
training for our teachers in the Summer
where they come down to nhti and
wherever they you're going to end up
doing that Shannon with death and and
the teachers teach teachers uh those
that are already involved with it they
teach and here's how we can help those
kids when they're in grades 11 and 12
after we gave them the Next Generation
math accuplacer test at the end of 10th
grade to determine how they're
functioning are they ready for algebra
two or not then we take them off and put
them into a math foundations then
quantitative math which prepares them
for going to it would be nice to have
something similar in the area of civics
I think it would be and I would speak I
know that we do a Southwest Center so we
do the monadnaught group it's like the
whole southwest corner and we do summer
Institute summer institutes with courses
and then we also do professional
development I would also assume Plymouth
does it too for their region I think if
money was put into support I mean
between UNH and employment than us I
think we could cover some of those
pieces in those areas and bring some
experts in that could do some of that
Civic engagement did you put it
we we put uh it was uh for the math
learning communities we did it with Beth
Dorian and Shannon we put 200 000 in
there that's was the initial grant that
Beth had received from the feds was for
200 Grand and we got 38 high schools
participating in it we ran out of grant
money and everything's still in statute
but there's no funding we put that money
why don't you add something in and when
and then we can work with the two you
know what whomever wants to help do that
it's
is there anything else I think we've
pretty much I'm looking at this doc here
the agenda what we had here
um
do the the Praxis test the last thing
which we had on this agenda
um
if you're going to get certification in
lower L
um what Praxis tests do you have to take
lower elementary K through five six so
the k-6 licensure they have um Praxis to
multi-subject tests so they have to and
the foundations of reading tests so the
multi-subject is language arts math
social studies and Science and the
foundations of reading is the literacy
test
and the Press oh practice core that's to
get into teacher Ed is a Praxis core
that's for all are you comfortable using
I mean there's pros and cons to
everything ironically
to today's conversation the area for the
practice too that students struggle with
passing is the social studies
um but it's not because of their
knowledge and understanding the practice
to for social studies for Led is the
same content the breadth and you know
the depth that is expected for the
Praxis too for the the social studies
for our K-12 but they keep switching it
but it's not as big of a test so our
students were studying you know being on
one area and then they study that to
retake it and it'll be a completely
different test so I think the um the the
test is is a difficult one that they
struggle with but it's not because they
don't know the social studies is trying
to prepare for such a broad test that
hmm
maybe they didn't have any social
studies when they're in high high school
or or Elementary School like I'm hearing
while they get to fourth grade New
Hampshire history
one day a year when they visit this Dome
for somebody because you know I sit
there looking at the tests and how do we
prepare and that's why we encourage them
to take the history course we found a
history course they'd help prepare them
but it is such a broad spectrum and it's
not they practice you know it just
didn't go oh this is for elementary what
do they need to know for social studies
nobody has stopped and said that it's so
broad I think if it was more focused
into that what they need to know for K
to six you know licensure I think the
test would be
um I I don't think it would be as much
of a struggle for students to pass
is there anything else that we need to
before before this group heads out I'd
like to know what are we looking forward
to review next I I know we have to
follow the that the bill which we passed
the what was it the 1530 the
the associate's degree leading towards
the junior year
finding out how that's working out or
all if has there been any positive
feedback negative feedback
I I'd like to know how that's working
what was the
was there a report from this committee
two years ago
it was a bill it was Representative no
no I know that but it but was there a
report from this committee and
um
it was
the Senate conducted that I'd have to
have to look I'm going back the last
um
August 18 2021
okay that would be two years ago yeah
yeah
so Senator Ward was chairing at that
time and that report's right here so we
should probably look at that report see
if there's any hope you know as homework
see if there's any action items like
well the big issue back then was dealing
with the community the merger remember
the merger and we had the subcommittee
here where they're going to merge the
two systems
and I'd be curious to know where we're
on that too Kathy Province should be the
one to contact
or Mark
nothing huh
I don't think we've gone anywhere on
that right right well I think I think
the question you raised Rick about the
matriculation
from associate degree to
the institution I'd be interested to see
where that is how many students take uh
advantage of that and what's been the
success of that program because I know
as I've talked with people around the
country when I mentioned that agreement
it's very popular from a standpoint of
we basically let part of the way in
doing that so let me ask as Tanya this
question so our kids coming down from
White Mountain Community College has a
two-year
ticket and they want to become you know
get a four-year degree from
King state are you going to accept those
credits or what's the process you're
going to take we don't accept all the
credits they they have agreements I do
know
um that a lot of our programs create
agreements with all the different
community colleges and they say take
this or take that
um I will say for Ed prep the difficult
thing is because of all the data and the
licensure requirements and our
accreditation requirements we will only
accept credits in our one in 200 level
courses we do not accept
um transfer credits in our methods
practicum and Beyond so if they had
taken an ed prep program at nhti we take
some of those and usually we do an
individual review but we do actually
have a um a a an agreement with them uh
if you take this it's equivalent to this
uh but it's interesting because they
take a bunch of courses and some of them
it doesn't always I mean it'd be nice at
some point to be like well they do this
and we do this like is there something
that meets in the middle I am now
working with uh uh CT Career and
Technical Ed that's starting a behavior
science program up in Claremont and they
actually asked us to come in earlier
because they're starting to form it and
so I have a colleague that's going to be
working with them so that they can look
at the courses when they create it how
it directly aligns to um to what you
know intro courses so that it makes it a
smoother transition for students when
they come in so some of those things are
happening as well but that's not for the
con Community College
you asked White Mountains Community
College Plymouth has been working a lot
with White Mountains Community College
to really smooth that pathway especially
in and as someone I worked at the
community college
um in a dual role prior to so I think
it's really important we've been doing
that um Outreach also with the Lakes
regions as well Community College and
really trying to smooth that pathway as
much as possible so yes that's been a
big part of our admissions program and
it will continue to be so to try to
remove barriers so that I agree students
pay for the credits at the community
college and then we want you know they
can transfer in
um and then towards getting a four-year
degree and I would say I think a lot of
the courtesy transfer intend to be to
our general education program the ISP
um and I think that
a lot of our liberal arts majors are
much more flexible with the um credits
coming in I see you know nodding her
head over there so I don't think it's as
like you do this you're in here it's
more looking at the programs and um
they're each kind of uh program specific
if that makes sense
I think that will be something we put on
the docket follow-up to the bill which
we passed which was hb1530
and we'll we'll follow up on that one
well I think you're uh I think I like
that the the article you give okay we
should spend some time talking about
that oh this right here
did everybody get a copy of this it's
out of the Wall Street Journal back on 2
3 23 so February 3rd
uh College doesn't need to take four
years
uh it was written by a Mr Wyatt a senior
executive director for Statewide online
education in the Utah system of higher
education
and uh Mr will guilezo is director of
the initiative on politics and
sportsmanship in Princeton University's
James Madison program
it's kind of an interesting article that
you know
you take a lot of this gen Ed stuff and
the stuff that you're really going to
need is the stuff you're taking for your
your skill that you want to go out and
work with in the career so there's I
think they're arguing here well since I
briefly read that I mean the whole
question is is do we move to a higher
education we just deal with a bunch of
badges that you're going to earn and
certificates you're going to earn and
how do you deal with with the liberal
arts as far as I'll give you an example
I was reading this I said now wait a
second I would know nothing about
monksan Michelle and short and and the
uh stained glasses in that Cathedral had
I not taken an art course which I didn't
want to take but so I mean there there
is a question that I'd like to entertain
with this committee about how do you
deal with just that badges approach of
just I'm going to get this certificate
that certificate every Visa B looking at
a more of a liberal arts approach of
maybe taking some stuff I really don't
want to take but when I take it I find
out hey there's something there that I
didn't want yeah and I think that's what
this is talking about I think as I
looked at this article that's what
that's really talking about what is a
general education that a student ought
to have before they started the
workforce or we just training them for
the workforce and then by the way I may
get into that Workforce and that's not
what I want to do and don't forget if
you're going to talk about Civics
education it's in the liberal arts that
you get the skills that help you
critically think and be creative and to
understand multiple cultures and
perspectives and those things so there
is a value and interesting enough and I
don't know if you could say this that
there are sometimes students that
they're going through and are at prep
program and someone like oh my head on
credits I want to do methods in
sophomore year and I'll look and I'll be
like that student's not ready the
maturity wise there's a development that
occurs through the four years and both
students and you know I was in chair at
the time were like oh no just let them
go on both of the students didn't finish
the program they struggled
um going into it so there is
it's a balance of EX you know being
exposed and kind of engaging in things
that you may not have and learning stuff
about yourself but also development that
happens in college that needs to be
appreciated
I think this article is trying to
capture the idea and it says it in bold
here for many students the standard
bachelor's degree program has become a
costly straight jacket
maybe we want to talk about that but but
there's a creating organizations well
beyond New Hampshire that are going to
I worked with the Northwest Association
of schools and colleges for a number of
years pardon me yeah
I got lots of copies of that we need to
have a time for our next one either okay
so good
well I understand it only took you eight
minutes to do one of those bills that
sent to us here so
it's over here in Delaware
it took us about hours and days
foreign yesterday
that we enrolled yesterday
we passed it and enrolled it this is the
city who said oh the sununa center yeah
so how about the eighth of May which is
me
okay that'd be great so let's
and there are those those would be two
items which are on the docket the two
okay let us know if if it's good
everybody and if there's a conflict
we'll look for another date
and so with that motion to adjourn
all in favor good thank you very much
thank you for coming today are you going
to be waiting for the the teacher
that's downstairs
and Steve Appleby will be here as well
if you know Steve you must know Dr
Appleby
thanks for all your work on the Civics
uh over there and appreciate that
thanks Rick well thank you very much
oh it's getting hot in here you know
because you've got a short sleeve shirt
yeah I got I got a t-shirt on too I'm
surprised